I want to share with you some
information that I will guarantee you
never heard before relating to your
liver now I'm going to go through two of
the signs of a fatty liver first and
then I want to explain something before
I get to the third one but
the first symptom or sign of a fatty
liver
is
there is no symptoms there is no signs
you have virtually no indication that
you have a fatty liver okay that's the
first one which is kind of like not
really a symptom but it's something you
should know so many people have a fatty
liver in fact 30 percent of all
overweight children have a fatty liver
okay and 40 of the entire population
have a fatty liver and the great
majority of them don't have a clue
because there are no symptoms now the
second most common symptom or sign that
you have a fatty liver is that your
midsection is protruding so if you look
down right now
at your abdomen
does it stick out
okay
you could have a fatty liver now this
next part is very very interesting so if
you've checked out just check back in
right now and really hear what I'm going
to say because the good news is the
liver is the only organ that you have
that you can get 100 percent repair and
regeneration
by volume and size
all the other organs the pancreas the
kidney
your lungs
you don't get 100 repair
but the liver you can but there is a
point of no return which I'm going to
explain next
so normally uh you have a fat cell that
over a period of time if you eat too
much or the wrong Foods it starts to
expand right it gets to a point where
there's a limitation of expansion
your fat cells do not have an unlimited
capacity to expand at some point
they hit their limit what happens next
is the fat cell becomes dysfunctional in
other words it starts to lose blood
supply it starts to become inflamed you
start developing fibrosis and scar
tissue around the fat cells
and they can no longer take in fat so
where does that fat go if you maintain
your lifestyle the way it's going well
it goes outside the fat cell it starts
to getting stored outside the fat cell
that's called ectopic fat
and I'm talking about in the muscles not
in blood cells just around the
pancreatic cells and the pancreas around
the heart cells around your kidneys okay
and there is a huge area that your body
can dump this fat in around the organs
in your abdominal cavity you can hold
four to six liters of this ectopic fat
very easily in your abdomen but that's
only the start because that abdomen can
start to expand outward more and more
and more to the point where you can hold
more of this ectopic fat okay
now the majority of fat in someone's
liver is this type of fat it's ectopic
it's not even in the fat cell this type
of fat is not a good healthy fat
this type of fat creates insulin
resistance now this next thing I'm going
to tell you is something
I didn't really fully know and
understand until very recently okay so
this is new information
I talked about the liver being ectopic
fat but I didn't tell you where the
source of that ectopic fat is really
coming from in the liver there's three
sources
just under 60 is 59 of the of the fat in
your liver actually originates from fat
outside your liver it's from fat in
other parts of your body that end up in
the liver sixty percent
wow that's crazy
so how can that happen well like I said
before this fat becomes damaged you can
no longer hold fat so you start getting
a breakdown of that fat and it starts to
Leach out through into the bloodstream
and it ends up in the liver okay so a
lot of the fat that you have in your
liver is come from other places in your
body which is interesting so that's 59
26 percent of the fat in the liver
actually comes from
your liver making its own fat from
glucose and so there's a process called
gluconeogenesis that is the production
of new sugar
it says nothing to do with eating sugar
it just has to do with your liver making
sugar from non-carbohydrate sources now
insulin is supposed to inhibit or stop
that process from happening normally in
students like okay liver you can't make
any more fat but because of all this
dysfunctional fat and the insulin
resistance now you have a deficiency of
insulin in the cells that's causing this
uncontrolled gluconeogenesis in the
liver so your liver is just making tons
and tons of sugar and this happens in
diabetes pre-diabetes and insulin
resistance and you'll see like diabetics
will wake up in the morning with the
dawn phenomena where all of a sudden
they have high sugar but sometimes if
they're on the ketogenic diet they're
not eating any sugar where is that Sugar
coming from it's coming from the liver
making all this sugar because of all
this dysfunctional fat and the insulin
resistance okay because there's there's
an insufficient amount of insulin there
to suppress this process from happening
but of course in the blood you have this
massive amount of insulin
but in cells you have a deficiency of
insulin so we have this severe imbalance
and the third source of actual fat comes
from dietary fat but that's because
you're also consuming sugar at the same
time how can I make this even more
simple well
when you consume a diet that's very high
in fructose or glucose or refined
carbohydrates that turn into glucose
you're going to create a situation where
the fat cells get overwhelmed and they
get to a point where they can't take in
any more fat it's going to spill off
into around the organs in your liver and
your abdominal cavity you're going to
develop insulin resistance but if you
check your blood sugar it'll be normal
for a while okay because everything is
compensating
but if you check the insulin it'd be
screaming high but doctors don't check
the insulin but if you check the blood
sugars it'll be normal for a while for
about 10 to 15 years
and then
little cells of the pancreas are just
exhausted now they can't make enough
insulin and now we get a much lowered
amount of insulin there's nothing to
buffer these blood sugars so now the
blood sugar starts going higher and
higher and higher and you have what's
called diabetes okay and they always say
a fatty liver is associated with you
know diabetes and metabolic syndrome and
high blood pressure but I think now you
can really see the source and what's
really cause and what's the effect of
this right we have the diet that this
two darn high in carbs that is actually
creating this insulin resistance and
it's damaging the fat cell and so
self-defeating Circle and cycle and one
thing worsens another and the whole
thing gets out of control but at the
very heart of this problem is the
person's consuming too many
carbohydrates now how do we know that is
that the source of it well very simply
if you
get someone on a low carb diet okay
what's going to happen is you start
correcting all of this you start
getting rid of the fat off the liver
very quickly within two weeks you can
drop 50 percent of that fat off the
liver if you do the ketogenic diet and
intermittent fasting so dropping the
carbs is going to be very very very
important now remember the liver is the
only cell that can completely 100
regenerate it takes a beating it can
rejuvenate but there is a point of
limitation if you have too much scar
tissue in there then there's going to be
a limitation of how much you can get
back but realize that we have the
dietary sugar that's creating a lot of
problems but we also have dysfunctional
fat cells throughout your body that's
ending up you know creating fat in the
liver and we're also having the liver
that's dysfunctional and it's making all
this extra sugar because there's no
insulin to suppress it okay but in your
blood you got tons of insulin all of
that can be corrected if you start to
cut down the carbs now you should also
know that the third symptom or sign that
you have a fatty liver is insulin
resistance there's quite a few
additional things to know that you have
insulin resistance but the real big one
is you cannot go for a long period of
time without needing food if you can go
a long period of time very easily
without food then chances are your
insulin resistance is much less of a
problem okay and you will see as you
start to lower your carbs and you start
to fast it becomes easier and easier and
easier that is one of the best
indications that you are correcting
insulin resistance okay so one way to
know if you still have insulin
resistance is can you fast for a long
period of time but also if you can wake
up in the morning without having high
blood glucose all right so cravings
can't go very long without needing food
fatigue I already mentioned that
frequent urination at night okay if you
have to get up at night to your night
chances are you have insulin resistance
and if you fix insulin resistance you
can fix this frequent urination problem
also feeling tired after lunch is a
common symptom
once you fix this your energy will
improve after lunch and throughout the
day and you'll have less brain fog
vision problems is another indication
that you have insulin resistance you may
think you're just getting old and you
need glasses but chances are it could be
just your blood sugar situation so the
three simple things that you need to do
is get on the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet with intermittent fasting
okay that's the most important thing
number two start exercising exercise
regular consistent exercise will improve
insulin resistance very potently and the
third thing to start consuming apple
cider vinegar like one to two
tablespoons of apple cider vinegar in
your water a few times a day apple cider
vinegar could do a lot for your
digestion but it can very potently
improve your blood sugars now that you
know this interesting association
between liver fat
and insulin resistance
you should check out this video that
gives you the complete knowledge on
insulin resistance and I put it up right
here